There are five sorts of classes involved in the visitor structure.
The participants, one is of course,
the visitor itself, which is an abstract class declaring a visit operation,
that is then applied by each of the concrete elements.
ConcreteVisitors are specialization of the visitor class,
implementing an operation on each of the concrete elements.
And, in addition, they may store local state, that is,
if your navigation wants to accumulate statistics,
there's a place to do that accumulation inside the ConcreteVisitor.
The Element class is an abstract class declaring the accept operation that takes
a Visitor as an argument.
It is sub-classed by Concrete Elements, representing the various different
kinds of nodes in the complex data structure, and
each of those elements takes an except operation with a Visitor as an argument.
Finally, the fifth of the classes is the Object Structure class,
itself, which usually provides a way of enumerating the various elements,
serving as the root of the data structure itself.